[Music]
for me Kingdom was one of the best
things about January the Korean Zombie
Horror Show had a hell of a lot going on
and it revitalized my interest in the
genre after The Walking Dead derail
their prey heavily with just a short six
episodes the show felt like it ended on
one of the best cliffhangers ever and if
like me you're clamoring to know more
then you come to the right place
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the release of season two and what
could happen in it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the ending of season
one and I highly suggest that you turn
off now but with that out the way I'm
definition and I watch it so you don't
have to season two as of this month
which is February 2019 in case you're
watching this in the future sees the
shooting of the second season of Kingdom
filming is due to finish in June which
means that the show will probably launch
in January 2020 when discussing the
script of season two ryu seung-ryong
sorry if i pronounced that wrong in an
interview with simp i said in season two
i think a lot of things are going to be
withdrawn i saw the script and i was
worried about how they were going to
handle everything in the end this story
also develops very quickly and i read
all the way through the script for
episode 4 in a flash characters other
than the main cast scene in season 1
will likely play a bigger role in season
2 when discussing his role as the
villainous senator the actor said he's
the non-zombie human presence in the
show that instills horror in viewers he
is a person that is keeping the king
chained up like a dog and giving him
food as if he's rearing him even so he
is not one bit shaken those kind of
actions are what's horrifying his
obsession with power to the point of
being almost reckless was fresh to me it
definitely feels like the horrifying
human aspect will get more light in this
second season and I really think that
this is a better direction to take the
show
the majority of the drama comes from the
senator and it will be outstanding if he
manages to weaponize the undead even
more than he did in the climax of the
first season that season of course ended
with the undead just about to swarm our
crown prince's location and swamp the
survivors with side characters getting
more of the spotlight here I would
imagine that we learn more about the
past of the princes allies including the
shadowy group of combatants the Queen's
plan will obviously play a huge role and
it seems that she's going to kidnap the
first male baby that comes from the
pregnant women in order to secure a
position as the unquestioned ruler of
the land obviously there's still a lot
that we don't know for the season and so
if you have any inside information or
know anything extra make sure you leave
a comment below if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my original breakdown on
season 1 which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
heavy into horror so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]